okay everyone recently we got a very
interesting clue about Avengers infinity
war from none other than Sebastian Stan
Bucky the Winter Soldier the movies
stars and directors have been hinting at
a massive battle set peace sequence
something like the airport battle in
Civil War but even bigger they indicated
somewhere around 40 major characters
involved in the sequence kind of like a
two-page spread in a comic book that you
just have to keep folding out and
folding out to see everybody in a recent
interview Stan said this about a quote
there was one scene I think we where we
had everybody they were there I can't
really talk about that scene but I knew
it took them three months in planning
this scene to have everyone there if you
look around and you just saw everyone
from samuel l.jackson to Michael Douglas
- Michelle Pfeiffer let's see well Nick
Fury and the older ant-man Hank Pym
that's Michael Douglas character I'm not
showing up in any trailers or promo
footage and Michelle Pfeiffer is playing
the original wasp Janet Van Dyne in the
upcoming ant-man in the wassalamu movie
she hasn't shown up in any trailers yet
the first day at man established that
Janet Van Dyne was missing in the
quantum realm the microscopic dimension
where you just shrink endlessly forever
and ever and it looks like the sequel
will focus partly on the search for
Janet but no one expected her to show up
in infinity war Stan may have gotten
confused and he might be referring to
the next movie Avengers 4 which is being
shot around the same time as infinity
war was but Stan's interview was
centered on this movie that's what
they're asking about so I don't know do
you guys think we could see the quantum
realm play a role in infinity war and
why how might the quantum realm connect
to what we already know about this movie
story that's a lot to do that's a long
set pieces I mean obviously they have to
1up themselves every movie and they're
like alright we had this amazing you
know the whole of Civil War was just
fantastic how do we raise and up the
stakes yet again I don't think it's
outside the realm of possibilities I
also think the Sebastian stent is a bit
of a troll and I was feeling that he is
watching us yeah I think either it might
have been confusion and he was just
talking about the two movies he's
working on the same time when this might
all be part of the same event so that's
why saying that we've now reached like
this new stage of stakes in this world
and maybe that's what he's referring to
just
for such an interesting name to bring up
you can have you can bring up any of the
76 characters that are gonna be in this
big showdown it sounds like either
ant-man the wasp takes place before
infinity war which would make more sense
because if everyone died at the end of
this it's like whoa what's going on
adventures caper of earth is dead we got
to get this weird suitcase with some Pym
tech make sure we get that back I was
thinking it's the other I think it's the
other Avengers he's shot they shot it
they are done with both movies he they
both if he's in that scene he would have
known about it so he may just gotten I
would be really excited to see how the
quantum realm because I love how like
the the that that other dimension could
work into the story we haven't really
seen the like reality stone in the
reality Jim come into play a lot there's
a lot of talk about how the time stone
or the space stone or the power stone
works but I think the the reality stone
has some other implications that we
haven't really explored and I think
going to the quantum realm could be a
fun way to look into that I think that
the very last second - is about to do
that and they're gonna he's gonna shake
out one of his little Deeley boppers
that shrink things really poppy he's
gonna throw like 50 of them that seems
like here in time or just shrink all it
tightens like the Avengers were there
it's like hey let's be honest this is
going bad yeah sorry we all had to make
a sacrifice here but you guys are in the
quantum realm now you can't hurt this
realm and I'll come get you guys
eventually I think it wasps - I'll be
down there in a second yeah
some man says that to himself inches out
in space and then winks and then a snaps
and cut the black
what a fun cliffhanger that could be
there's a lot of characters in this but
let us know what you think about
Sebastian Stan's comments do you want to
see the quantum realm and the ant-man
decided the characters or what Nick Fury
might be doing in this movie we haven't
seen him in any trailers either down
below tweet us directly ID a vas
remember to subscribe to new rock stars
on what what platform are we on you -
you - yeah for all of our coverage we
are in the midst of infinity week
everything we're talking about is
infinity war there's so much to talk
about we're super excited this is
happening
but yeah thanks guys